hey guys Pete here today I'm going to go
back and do my top moments video for
Twin Peaks season 3 episode 9 - bit
backwards I know but this is these are
fun videos to make honestly and you know
the show is fun to watch and I like to
talk about it so jump right into it
first big moment was Tim Ross arrival
found out that he was hutch we heard
about hutch way back when we first met
Chantal and he is an interesting
character it is kind of interesting
though that I don't know that how much
we're going to see of him after this
part you know what I mean there's been a
lot of different cameos where people
have shown up and we don't really know
if they're coming back or not I'm a Tim
Roth fan I enjoy his delivery and I hope
we see more pudge for sure and his
counterpart Chantel Jennifer Jason Leigh
because they seem like good characters
that could definitely steal some
episodes the next big moment for me was
seeing
Coop's new truck as soon as he came
around the corner and we saw that the
farmers were laying there presumably
dead you could see the front end of this
thing sitting there and it's just like
this is definitely an evil coupe mobile
you know what I mean so I was glad to
see that he drove off in it and I hope
that it plays a good part in the rest of
the season as well let's talk moment for
me was Duncan Todd like I don't know
what it is about this guy scenes but I
realized each time when I go back and
re-watch it I really like the way that
this character is played by the actor
and of course you know there's some
intrigue involved because we saw him
talk directly to evil Cooper this time
and we know that he's been doing his
bidding and that there may be some
connection with him outside of that like
maybe some Phillip Jeffries or something
else so mr. Todd has been with us the
whole way and I think that he's
definitely in the middle of something
and I hope we find out more about it the
next big moment was we found out from
the Cisco brothers that dougie Jones has
no records or history of existence
before 1997 the
is the catalyst for them getting his
prints although quite a few people have
mentioned that they should have his
prints already from the gun either way
we got there they are looking into who
he is and why they don't know anything
about him they're actually going to get
a surprise we know that they're going to
find out that it's Agent Dale Cooper not
dougie Jones but it definitely leads to
the mystery of what evil kook did to
bring this dougie Jones character into
the story so that he could be taken into
the Black Lodge instead of evil coop
himself the next big moment was seeing
Johnny Horne run through the house and
smash his head on the wall I mentioned
in my 10 things you might have missed
videos that this could be a relation to
him being involved in richard horn like
maybe he's the father but the prevailing
theory nowadays is that Johnny's going
to pass away here or that you know he
basically killed himself and that's
going to be the reason that Audrey comes
back to Twin Peaks it makes a lot of
sense the family would be mourning there
would be a funeral and that would mean
that wherever she's at that she would
have to probably come back because after
all that is her brother the next one
would in most cases be my favorite
sequence if not moment of the season and
that was Betty Briggs's delivery of the
metal canister to frank truman and
deputy hawk and her son Bobby breaks
this may have been eclipsed by the new
character towards the end but this is a
great call back to the original run it's
a great call back to Donna Davis who
passed away who played major Briggs and
it was just a really cool scene all the
way around and I have to admit that I
had no clue or ever read anybody
theorizing that perhaps major Briggs put
everything in place before he
disappeared so that this could all
happen I mean this was a complete
surprise to me and it was great the
chair was the next big moment I mean he
basically laid all this stuff
out and we even see later that he had
done a couple things with Bobby says
that Bobby would be ready to receive
these clues whenever things came
together so it was great the music I
mentioned in my last video as well you
know the music kicking in while she's
sitting there and her putting up her
hand and saying wait I already know why
you're here I mean it was awesome it was
just a great callback in a great scene
and it really gets the wheels turning as
far as like what's going to happen when
they actually make it to Jackrabbits
palace
so yeah the you know the next thing
would be all of this Bobby stuff I mean
after the chair after the cylinder or
before the cylinder I guess you know she
says that major Briggs had said that she
was you know he was sure that everything
would turn out and I have to admit I'm
not a big I was never a big Bobby fan
he's not a character that I really cared
for but you know his father on the other
hand was one of my favorites and all
this stuff that went down between them
now makes a lot it makes it a lot better
for me you know and it makes me like
Bobby actually some so the fact that
dana Ashbrook is you know he shows a
little bit of range here and he does a
pretty good job it only makes it better
and I really do enjoy thinking about
where what part Bobby's going to play in
light of the fact that major Briggs
won't be actually able to be in any new
scenes it also makes me think about it
also makes me think about Shelli and
Becky you know we found out Shelli has
this daughter named Becky and she's in
trouble more or less we don't really
know how things resolved between Shelli
and Bobby we haven't seen them or heard
of them in the same conversation so
there is an outside possibility that
Becky could be Bobby's daughter which
would make her major Briggs his
granddaughter so she might have a
different purpose than what we have
already seen but that's a little bit out
there it's just something that pops in
mind you know after the fact the next
big moment was Diane and her smoking at
the coroner's office
obviously when she dropped the line it's
a [ __ ] morgue that was a moment
um yeah I don't know I can't foresee the
time when this gets old like I really a
tropic Diane and her not giving a [ __ ]
attitude you know she's a great
character also Albert sort of follows
this up and is not going to be outdone
as he's walking down the hall listening
to the detective talk about everything
that happened in Hastings life he pulls
out one of the best and funniest things
where he says what happens in season two
I think that you know this was probably
the funniest line in this episode but I
don't think it eclipses his when he was
going to meet Diane the first time
whenever he curses Gene Kelly I think
that's still my favorite Albert moment
of the season so far right after that
the next big moment was Diane receiving
the text from at the time we thought it
was evil Cooper maybe it is maybe it's
been relayed from someone else either
way that was obviously a big moment I've
had a lot of people comment and bring up
the idea that she has a white black and
red nail I didn't really pay that much
attention to this I to me it looks great
I didn't see it as white and black I saw
it as gray red and black and it sort of
goes with what she was wearing but a lot
of people have brought it up there's a
lot of people talking about the idea
that it's a clue towards the lodges but
I don't know why we need that right
there I mean it's cool if that's what it
is
but evil coupe is a doppelganger that
has come directly from the lodges so I'm
not sure what additional context that
would add here if you know what I mean I
don't think she's a doppelganger or that
she's been to the Black Lodge but we
don't know for sure I guess you know
maybe that night the last time she saw
evil Cooper more that's what we think
happened happened but either way it is a
thing it's a thing you can think about
if you'd like we'll see what nail color
she has next episode the next moment I
think was probably Jerry versus his own
foot and I mean I guess it's a little
bit corny and all that but I really find
this mystery because him being in the
woods like I
I could totally see why someone might be
like this is stupid it takes up time or
whatever because he's basically just a
hi old man but I think there's probably
something more to it why it which is why
it's it's tolerable and enjoyable at the
same time plus it he's an original
character and he's changed quite a bit
and it's interesting to see where he
goes you know the next big moment is the
opening of the metal cylinder I touched
on this before so I won't go on to that
much but you know Bobby knowing how to
do it because major break showed him is
a big part of that but also what is
inside and I've talked about this in
both the recap and the you know recap
and review and the 10 things you might
have missed so we don't really need to
go into it again but yeah I mean I've
got my anticipation level way up in
relation to this Jackrabbits palace and
I'm sure everyone else does as well
after that the next big moment was Bill
Hastings his interview and the different
information that he brought out
obviously it was played really well by
the actor and as I mentioned I think
Tammy did a great job in the scene too
but yeah just so much information which
I've already touched on so we don't have
to go back into it but it's just it's
just really cool that we know someone
outside of Twin Peaks has had contact
with major Briggs had some understanding
of what's happening whether it's you
know what I don't know if he really
knows or if he just lucked into it but
based on the fact that the search for
the zoom websites there and there's a
lot of information there that ties in to
some of the things we've seen I think
that you know Bill Hastings will
actually be somewhat I was a resource
going forward in a lot of ways so yeah
that was a huge moment hopefully it
won't be like multiple episodes until we
get back to that storyline I you know we
don't really know but obviously there's
something that's going to go down within
the next couple of days and we know that
evil coupe and the guys in Twin Peaks
are onto it so we'll see what happens
there
in the last big moment is the
friggin rash that this girl has at the
Roadhouse I mean I didn't think too much
of it at first it seems like it's
probably related to the batch of drugs
the sparkle that red has brought into
town and richard horne is pedaling
around you know we did get indication
that someone overdosed in Twin Peaks and
that's been happening and this scene was
kind of kind of easy to forget about
towards the end because of what happened
before it but yeah this brash is pretty
insane and I really doubt that we won't
hear more about it so yeah that's that's
those were my moments what do you guys
think leave me some comments let me know
if these were about the same thing that
you were thinking about if there was
other things that I missed please like
the video if you enjoyed it and
subscribe to my channel thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon